Iliads idea was this,
that things fall apart of their own
accord merely because they age that
that's the first motif in the flood
story and that's only to say that if you
build something,
it indicates if you build something and
you just leave it the hell alone,
it will soon not work.
Right?
And that's entropy.
So one of the reasons that the flood
always threatens is merely because of
entropy.
And you see that reflected in the
Egyptian story because one of the
reasons that,
oh,
cyrus falls prey to seth is because
these old,
you know,
he was a great hero when he was young
and created the Egyptian state,
like the men of renown.
But now he's old and it's worse.
He's willfully blind,
but that's the next thing.
But the fact that he's old is just to
start things fall apart of their own
accord.
So once something is given to you,
you have to maintain it just to ensure
its continued existence.
And so you actually,
you actually have a contract with most
of the things that you own.
It's like a,
it's like a moral contract.
Let's say you have a car or you've
decided that you're going to sacrifice
to have the car and so you've,
you've performed an ethical calculation,
but the car was only worth the sacrifice
as long as it functions as a car and so
what that means is that to justify the
sacrifice you've made,
to have the car,
you have to maintain the car because
otherwise you're acting out the
proposition that the thing you
sacrificed for actually didn't have any
value and so your obliterating that as a
useful contract and you run into the
situation where the car will just
deteriorate of its own accord and then
you won't have a car at all.
Well,
so let's say,
how do you speed the process by which
your car deteriorates?
Well,
that's easy.
You're driving it along the road and it
starts to make a ticking noise.
Tick,
tick,
and you think I should go have that
ticking noise checked because you've
heard it and then you think,
Nah,
it won't matter.
It's like,
yeah,
probably it will matter.
And what is matter mean well matter his
mother.
That's chaos to you no matter.
But what it means is that that little
ticking noise is the birthplace of tire
matt in your car.
That's a good way of thinking about it
is that it's your first indication that
the dragon of chaos is going to manifest
itself in your car.
That happens when you.
I've got a funny story about that.
So I had a friend in graduate school,
someone I really liked,
but I wouldn't call her mcelliott
mechanically inclined,
let's put it that way.
And she had an old Honda and those
things were notorious for rusting out.
This is 30 years ago when they were
first produced.
They weren't adapted well to Canadian
winters and we used to go into her car
and her Honda and it got a little on the
scary side because it was so rusty
underneath that you can actually see
through the floorboards.
And that actually made me nervous
because if you can see through the
floorboards,
that means that they're not really
floorboards.
What they are is like rust.
And so I mentioned the fact that that
might be a problem to her a couple of
times,
but she was sort of blind about it and
one day she was driving down St Lawrence
Street in Montreal,
which is the main running roughly north
and south and her hood popped up it band
and popped up spontaneously.
And so she was really curious about
that.
And so she was with this friend of hers
and was just as clueless mechanically as
she was,
which is really quite remarkably
clueless.
And so they pulled off into a service
station and had the guy come out and
look at it.
And well,
he,
he opened the hood obviously.
And what had happened was the body had
fallen off the frame.
So.
And what had happened was the shock,
which is supposed to be attached to the
car,
had pushed up through the,
through the,
the hood.
So literally the car body had fallen
onto the ground and.
But she was,
she managed to drive the cart.
Okay.
So look,
that's,
I wouldn't exactly call that willful
blindness because perhaps there is an
element of willful blindness.
She didn't know anything about
mechanics,
but you get the point,
right.
It's like,
let's say she would been in a fatal
accident.
You might say,
well,
you can shake your fist at God for
producing the circumstances,
but you know the fact that you could see
through the floorboards,
that's probably something that you might
have paid attention to,
and so it's always.
The question is this,
if things fall apart around you,
to what degree is it the mere tendency
of things to degenerate entropically
because they do that of their own accord
or have you sped the probability of
decay by failing to pay attention?
When a little snake manifests itself
inside your paradise.